はいって
奈良田把握した皆さんハンドスピナーというものをご存知でしょうか
もうユーチューバーた琵琶湖沿いもこぞって反動スピナーの動画だし上がってほんと
メットか言いながら僕もやるんですけどもうそんなねしょうがないこと僕ハンド
スピナーでしたくないんで
そもそもしょうもないしどうせだったらもっと判断スピナーを使ってすごいことができ
ないかなと思いまして
こちら補助セミナーです
ねえん
こうすればマールやってですこれでまあと指の間でちょっとまあプレっていうなんとも
なんとも特徴のない表なんですけども僕このハンドスピナーの案で特徴に目をつけまし
たこれ形を見てもらったら分かると思うんですけど
いかにも他のハンドスピナーと合体したそうにしてるように見えないかそうなんです僕
はそこに目をつけてしまった反動スピナーとでもう一個あるとこうつなげれるんじゃ
ないかと
思いましてそんなスピードてないんですけども一つをまーすと
マリネ詰まるというこういう原理があると思いまして
こういう集まりのも回るんですよてな感じで賛同スピナーを一つ回しては他のマール
ねーずも全部回るんじゃないかと思いまして
わーやるだけちょっと文字この原理で行くとここには先行の艦娘ながるんですけどもう
ちょっとしたら指一本で&スペ7000
うっきーまずいかもしれないできるかわかんができるかわかんないしてを育ててきたの
高速回転なんで定期やしないそれでもいいそれでもいいんです
&スピナーのこの回りやすい性質めどに歯車チェックでフィットしそうな感じ
ウォーカーそんなハンドスピナー
[音楽]
指一本で
先行馬をしたいんです
出会いカフェではいうことが入ったけどあと2泊あるんだんっ
はそもそも成功並べられるのゴールのいてみただっしーはそこからじゃ別の箱になっ
てるなんですよ
今中に入ってるんかじゃあやべえ俺全部ハンドスピナーだからねえパターンとぞ
4棟大田フィーロ切る4
白粗飯スピナーが1000個一か所に集まること自体そうそうないことだと思うので
とりあえずでハンドスピナー戦後箱から出して回せる状況まで何とかしてみようと思い
ます
後輩とね全員色合いはこちらの5色展開となっております2にほしいってが居るのだ
うっねばおいていきます
[音楽]
4日
はいやフィルと中で思ったんですけども床が踏める
行く載せるのでちょっとこのまま食べましてもすぐ入って泣くんで一応だか滑れない
ようなシートがあるので下に
すべらないシートを引きます
[音楽]
me
これがないばあ
なんかここ書等別宅て飛び出てるやつがあるんですよね
それだとただのハンドだよ
[音楽]
me
ここまで赤青緑
k ちょっ並べていた途中に苦労が出来ました
米も同じ雑記0の法則が見られる野菜なんか本当は5色できれいに並べたかったんです
けどもう誰で行くきれいに並べていきたいと思いますでは
[音楽]
ん
me
ああああああ
ni
[音楽]
ジャイアンチャッチャはいというわけで終了しました
a と言いつつもずつは戦後全部を受けているわけではありません滑るシートのサイズ
的にもこれだけしか置けなかったんですけども戦って本近くあるんだこれだけ並べるの
荷台で3時間ちょいかかりました
ソトアサレシピやけれども完璧に並びましたからね全てのハンドスピナーの歯車同士が
儲かってると噛み合っておりこっち側んじゃなかった罪な甥っ子を抑えて高回すと全て
がレーサー反応してきれいに回転してしまうこれであるまでは戦後でを回ると思うんだ
よねー
ませんぎょうしょん3トゥ
th
me
うううう
ああああああ
me